welcome to robot babies gentlemen are  you ready to see the next big thing  let's hear it for the new school what's  that an e all children must be  accompanied by an adult you're coming  with me young lady  [Music]  hello maybe we could try and be friends  you're gonna stay here tonight not you  mom oh I knew that you judging me bra  yeah you being here is like the best  thing to happen to me why don't you put  weapons in a robot something terrible is  about to happen  holy mother toast seven seven two three  is our only hope there's way too much  injustice in the world together we can  fix it I promise I got your back  [Music]  No  he's so cool  [Music]  what do you call him my friend Wow thank  you for opening me oh look out here I go  closing  [Music]  you